افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت الحي الشرقي من جنين
مصحوبه بعدد من الجرافات ما ادى الى
اندلاع اشتباكات مع فصائل المقاومه
وانطلقت صفرات الانذار في المدينه ومخيمها
وهذه صور لاصوات الاشتباكات ودوي صفاره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاند
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واصيب شاب فلسطيني برصاص قوات الاحتلال
خلال اقتحامها بلده يعبد جنوب غرب مدينه
جنين وافاد مراسلنا ان قوات اسرائيليه
اقتحمت عده مناطق في البلده ودهمت عددا من
المنازل وفتشتها وان عشرات الشبان
الفلسطين
خرجوا لصد الاقتحام فرد جنود الاحتلال
باطلاق الرصاص الحي ما اسفر عن جرح شاب
فلسطيني وقد انسحبت قوات الاحتلال من
البلت معنا الان من جنين علي الصمودي علي
ارحب بك اخر التطورات لديك
نعم لليوم الثاني على التوالي تواصل قوات
الاحتلال استهداف مدينه ومخيم جنين وتنفيذ
العمليات التي كان يتوقعها الجميع بعد
العمليه التي نفذت الاسبوع الماضي في حي
الجابريات في مدينه جنين واسفرت عن مقتل
مجنده واصابه عدد اخر من الجنود الان قوات
الاحتلال تطلق النار على كل جسم يتحرك في
الحي الشرقي من مدينه جنين ومحيط منطقه
حليمه السعديه لذلك نحن لم نتمكن من
الدخول الى تلك المنطقه بسبب الانتشار
الاسرائيلي وعمليات اطلاق النار التي
استهدفت كل من يتحرك في المنطقه قبل حوالي
ساعه بدات قوات الاحتلال
بعمليتي الشرقي ومحيط مسجد خالد بن وليد
ومنطقه حليمه السعديه وجميعها تقع في
المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه جنين هذه
المنطقه التي تشهد الان اشتباكات مسلحه
عنيفه ما بين المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال وسط
القاء العبوات الناسفه قوات الاحتلال كما
قال شهود العيان للجزيره الان تقتحم
العمارات والابنيه المرتفعه في المنطقه
وتقوم باحتلال المنازل ونصب القناصه عليها
تقول ان هنالك عدد من الفلسطينيين الذين
تقع منازلهم في تلك المنطقه وهم مستهدفين
ومطلوبين لذلك هي تبدا بالتوغل وبالتوجه
نحو منازل اسرهم في محاوله لمحاصرته او
اعتقالهم الاحتلال ل الاسرائيلي احتجز
العديد من المواطنين الذين كانوا في
طريقهم من منازلهم الى اماكن عملهم في
جنين واعتدى عليهم بالضرب بينما نشر
التعزيزات والدوريات في كل ركن وزاويه من
الحي الشرقي في مدينه جنين نحن الان في
وسط المدينه قوات الاحتلال كانت امس هنا
وقامت بعمليات تخريب ومداهم وخاصه في
الحسبه القريبه لكن يبدو اليوم العمليه
تتركز في الحي الشرقي الان الاحتلال يحاصر
المنطقه المطقه الصناعيه في جنين ومحيط
المدارس والواضح ان هنالك المزيد من
التعزيزات فقد بلغنا ان هنالك دوريات
عسكريه تتحرك في محيط الجلم هذا هو
الاقتحام ال 30ث لمنطقه جنين منذ عمليه
طوفان الاقصى وقوات الاحتلال التي قتلت
اكثر من 80 فلسطينيا في محافظه جنين خلال
هذه الفتره لا ولا تتوقف عن عمليات
الاستهداف والدهم وقد قام ضباط ال الشباكي
الاسرائيلي الليله الماضيه بالاتصال مع
مجموعه من المقاومين الذين يقولون انهم
مطلوبين وهددوهم باغتياله وهددوا بنسف
منازلهم اذا لم يسلموا انفسهم لذلك ومع
انتهاء هذه المهله الان الاحتلال يبدا هذه
الحمله التي تستهدف منازل المطلوبين الذين
قالت انها ستقوم باعدامهم بل وطلبت من
اسرهم ان يحفروا قبور لهم اذا لم يسلموا
انفسهم للاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي يطلق
الان النار على كل جسم يتحر في الحي
الشرقي من مدينه جنين ثم اقتحم حي حليمه
السعديه المجاور له وهنالك اقتحام ومداهم
في منازل الفلسطينيين واحتجازهم وبالتالي
نصب القناصه على المنازل لرصد تحركات
المقاومين رغم ذلك هنالك استنفار في جنين
والمخيم وهنالك اشتباكات مسلحه في العديد
من المحاور لم نبلغ حتى هذه اللحظه عن
اصابات
واعتقالات